[Musik]
auf und davon mit der mobiliar
versicherungen und vorsorge ein hof am
see silvia und marcus burg suchen die
ruhe in schweden
sie wollen dort ferienwohnungen
vermieten wie war mary kom stefano lotti
und stefano navarrete zieht es in die
karibik im land ist tequila wittern sie
ihre chance und familie zogaj möchte
sich in südafrika neu erfinden
ihr traum eine eigene lodz
[Musik]
sylvia bauer bis die nachtstunden mit
ihrem mann verabredet in schweden er ist
schon unterwegs mit dem auto und den
umzugskisten die lange fahrt wäre zu
anstrengend für die schwangere mutter
und schwester blieben gerne bis zur
geburt ins meer
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
tief
[Musik]
und 5
in der letzten folge räumten ihre
wohnung auch wenn der hand wechselt für
ihren hof am see noch nicht über die
bühne ist aber ihr baby soll unbedingt
im neuen zuhause zur welt kommen familie
türkei gab ihr einfamilienhaus am
bodensee auf obwohl ihr projekt einer
gästefarm in südafrika auf der kippe
steht
die beiden stefano bauern für ihren
start in mexiko auch auf ihr netzwerk in
der schweiz und in cancún erwartete sie
stefanos onkel bereits sehnlichst
[Musik]
tag eins im neuen leben von stefano
navarrete und stefano lotti vor knapp
zwölf stunden sind die baselbieter in
mexiko angekommen
[Musik]
stephanus onkel fernando importiert
italienische lebensmittel besitzt eine
pasta fabrik ein hostel und investiert
in immobilien
sein neffe soll so schnell wie möglich
in die geschäfte einsteigen
[Musik]
das geschäftshaus gehört fernando es
gibt nur ein paar blocks von seiner
villa entfernt
plaza italia
in der plaza italia haben sich
verschiedene unternehmen eingemietet
hier soll bald der verlor nach dem
rechten schauen
so hat es der onkel vorgesehen
von der 10
[Gelächter]
die erste aufgabe für den jungen chef
einen vertrag aufsetzen für einen neuen
mieter
für alles was ich tue ich bin hier schon
viele jahre allein und so habe gesagt
ich brauche sich jemand etwas verdreht
weil ich nicht hier will unser geschäft
ist ganz groß gegangen und er natürlich
nicht die besten schweizer schule so
ganz was wir brauchen ja wie sie mich
jetzt schon gehen ohne zu denken oder ab
sofort eilt sich der onkel die führung
der geschäfte mit seinem neffen sind
schöne junge frauen haben sich da
präsentiert und dadurch natürlich wenn
man sich gut vorstellen
[Musik]
alles anders als geplant bei familie
zogaj perfekt super series 2 blue sky
also direkt am strand war der größte
die auswanderer aus dem thurgau suchen
ein haus ihr projekt mit erfahrung hat
sich zerschlagen
sie konnten keinen neuen investor mehr
auftreiben
jetzt müssen sie sich neu orientieren
bis sie ein haus findet zieht die
familie von hotel zu hotel
ich glaube ich habe fertig aber noch
ohne strom
jetzt wartet man im moment geht gar
nichts mehr
kein netz kein heim keine idee wovon sie
leben können
ein anderer punkt jetzt sondern aber das
ist auf der andere sieht dann auch die
dynamik aber nicht gesagt aber ich finde
das so spannend und es ist momentan noch
so cool oder das eigentlich alles noch
offen ist und sich somit taste und luigi
wenn er richtig hasten und das macht
seinen akku in panik
alles ist schrecklich oder so das
desaster weil es das immer dann ins netz
oder nun will vielleicht nicht alles
nach plan laufe ich meine 20 oder mit
einigen stature boxster oder da wurde
das auf anhieb so ablaufen muss man kein
scharfes leben und damit wusste daher
galt jetzt natürlich hoffte
[Musik]
mehr als 1500 kilometer mit dem auto hat
marcus burg hinter sich seit gestern
quer durch deutschland und dänemark auf
dem rücksitz handy pieper ins land der
seen ja selbst versorgen war der zöllner
supernett alles perfekt funktioniert
dann haben wir noch gott mal im café
kann sowohl das orchester zu fangen
willkommen also
sich die gab perfekt die feierstunde
schwede super-g den nächsten 40 jahren
genau so wie es geplant
[Musik]
die neue heimat der burg in südschweden
rund 8000 menschen leben hier in der
geburtsstadt von astrid lindgren
[Musik]
auf dem marktplatz hat markus seine
erste verabredung in schweden mit
ehefrau händler
[Musik]
der umzug läuft wie am schnürchen
genauso wie budzin geplant haben
[Musik]
ihr hof am see liegt in snooker born
einem weiler acht kilometer von wien
entfernt - vater und ihr onkel helfen
beim zügeln
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
der schlüssel zu neuen heim
der vorbesitzer hat in den neuen
hausherrn überlassen obwohl den burgs
der hof noch nicht gehört
[Musik]
deshalb ist auch seit bruch im
kühlschrank
frische blumen musik dafür dass alles so
gut macht
die sandwich torte mit shrimps gibt es
später zum nachtessen
aber bis dahin hatten die helfer aus der
schweiz noch ein letztes mal mit an
[Musik]
[Applaus]
onkel fernandos villa in kranken die
beiden stefano konnten bis jetzt hier
unterkommen heute packen sie ihre sachen
und fahren weiter zu ihren eigenen
wohnungen
fernando hat alles vorbereitet hilft
ihnen sogar beim visum für mexiko das
neue daheim der beiden liegt nicht in
cancún sondern in playa del carmen eine
autostunde südlich der kleinwagen gehört
zum deal den stefano mit seinem onkel
abgeschlossen hat kaufte mir zu schaffen
machen wenn ich musik kleidung kongo
füreinander und seine freundin kommen
selbstverständlich mit
der onkel macht den schweizern den start
so leicht wie möglich
in südafrika hat die familie talkerin
noch keine zündende idee für ihre
zukunft sie besichtigen erstmal
verschiedene häuser und hoffen so einen
schritt weiter zu kommen
eigentlich wollten die talks hier
touristen beherbergen und sie im eigenen
restaurant bewirken
dafür brauchen sie die passende
liegenschaft ja ganz wichtig ist
bausubstanz sondern weil ganz klar ist
dass in südafrika wirklich anders
sportvideos qualität von dieser variiert
extrem indicators einem touristenort
haben sie ein haus mit meerblick
entdeckt der makler erwartet sie bereits
das haus mit der atemberaubenden sicht
bietet platz für zwei familien rund
300000 franken soll die villa kosten
[Musik]
okay okay
ja aber das risiko ist da oder
das ist so weiter geht's zum nächsten
termin
[Musik]
zwischen blühenden zucker büschen mitten
in einer protea plantage stoßen die
talker ist auf eine campinganlage fünf
große luxus zelte am ufer eines sees
also ich schon lustig immer einer ist
die schulung steht doch lustig ich es ok
megastar schnitt das bett das ist frisch
gemacht da ist das mitführen
[Musik]
und da wird es nicht aber mir wäre das
anders machen erfahrungen mit dem der
traum von der gästefarm ist noch in
weiter ferne
dafür haben sie alles aufgegeben ihre
sicheren jobs den freundeskreis das
einfamilienhaus am bodensee
[Musik]
sommer das ganze jahr hindurch alltag im
ferienort playa del carmen hier in der
casa italia besitzen di stéfano sie eine
wohnung ihre wohnungen auf der einen
seite ihr haus gleich nebenan mit
fernanda zusammenbauen sie hier
appartements für das erdgeschoss hat
fernando sogar schon mieter gefunden
[Musik]
stefano tier zieht vorübergehend bei
stefano navarrete ein sein appartement
ist noch vermietet die wohnung ist schon
kopiert und mit dem nötigsten
eingerichtet dem onkel sei dank
funktioniert auch onkel fernando hat ein
appartement im haus
[Gelächter]
von hier aus wollen die stephanus ihre
immobilien geschäfte aufziehen
ja jetzt
dass ich das ist der blick von jeder
morgens blick und jeder motor nicht mehr
so dass ich super
[Musik]
früh am morgen ins nokia drei
möglichkeiten sie stiegen aber die musik
zehn minuten slowakisch teams zum fahrer
das thema es ist großartig dass ich hab
ja nein denn die u 17 minuten das
stammgeschäft der autobahn sowie als
onkel ist startklar für die rückfahrt
vater theo fällt der aufbruch schwerer
als gedacht schwiegersohn tochter und
das baby sind ab jetzt nicht mal eben
für einen spontanen besuch erreichbar
logwin
ja auch scooter gute start
euro
[Musik]
liga
nötig war
[Musik]
ja
ab jetzt sind die bugs auf sich allein
gestellt die 2 bald 3
es werde zwischen dem 17
[Musik]
das auto mit anderen zügen so lieb warum
playa del carmen für die stephanus der
platz für große träume
[Musik]
wunderschön
fotos war der felidae ein stoff
inspiration ist kreativ thalia tiefe
wasser projekt immer unterwegs etwas
mehr stefanos stefanou haben auf der
baustelle nebenan einen termin mit ihrem
bauleiter er ist ja nachbarn und
natürlich italiener zwei ladenlokale und
15 appartements werden hier in wenigen
monaten aus dem boden gestampft funktion
[Musik]
das geld für den bau kommt von stefanie
und stefan das grundstück gehört
ungefähr nennt
naja wir vertrauen die apartments wollen
sie so schnell wie möglich an touristen
vermietet darunter yahoo sido vergesst
also quintiq von rambus unglaublich
unglaublich
du wirst du ich sage ich aus gefühlen
das ist sehr gut voran und wir sind sehr
gut im zeitrahmen nicht dank dem schon
so weit sind also super wenn es ist ja
unser perfekter
[Musik]
die bachelors brille nötig sei ja das
lied hey das land in sicherheit gebracht
denn aldi talk packen einmal mehr ihre
sachen und sehen in ihre nächte bleiben
diesmal für mehrere monate und etwas
preisgünstiger bis jetzt leben sie immer
noch von ihren ersparnissen
das konzept ist nach wie vor das man
halt die jugend es im gästebereich
machen längerfristig sicher irgendwie
ein guesthouse ob sie vom vom effektive
betriebskonzept dass ich mal offen
dann machen wir abhängig von den war mir
schluss 1 befindet und wo wir dann
nachher werden iittala leben aus dem
koffer
so geht das schon seit mehreren wochen
und bald kommt der container aus der
schweiz mit 75 kubikmeter hausrat vor
allem mika und anni kommen nicht mehr
zur ruhe
einfach mehr sagen sie schnupfen und auf
die andere seite mal was machen und ich
finde sie es anspruchsvoll mit kritik
und für die automobil und maschinenbau
darum bin jetzt einfach immer gratis
bei bucher ich sollte so schnell gibt
aber nicht auf er glaubt fest an ein
gutes ende ihrer auswanderungs
geschichte
[Musik]
in lugo sind die box voller tatendrang
zu ihrem hof am see gehören drei wohnen
und sieben nebengebäude
dazu kommen zehn hektar umschwung schon
bald wollen sie hier ferienwohnungen
vermieten aber zuerst müssen sie die
häuser sanieren
die top 100
in wenigen wochen kommt der erste gast
handy ist natürlich die vermieter sind
was man machen was man daraus ein mann
informierte die summe müsste mir die
trophäe
außerdem geht sich sozusagen und
diskussion schätze ich war dafür dass
martelly würden wir es auch rauchen oder
lancieren dass sie aus albert und markus
stähli lämmer und holz dass es mehr
ausgeht
ich bin eine das wirklich machen und
dann möge wie sie musik und das
theoretisch kamera das und dann müsst
ihr einfach nur machen kann so praktisch
nichts liefert der kontraste bist du dir
vorstellen will
es ist einfach noch durch linie und
einfach locker das muss so viel
helligkeit wie möglich ruhe bringen
ohne zuwies machen nein es wird nie
thema holz und delhi wird immer nur
lancieren
ihr würdet struktur und ab
[Musik]
oh mein papa geht es in schweden gut
auch ohne klare umbaupläne ihr genügend
die neue freiheit und die grenzenlosen
möglichkeiten
[Gelächter]
zielloses herumstreunen kann markus
momentan nicht gebrauchen
[Musik]
auf der baustelle der beiden stefano der
tat gearbeitet
200 pesos umgerechnet etwa 10 franken
verdienen die arbeiter pro tag
ich war schon wieder träume schnell zum
bayern schock davon
[Musik]
in der schweiz haben die beiden viel
geld verdient mit einer personalagentur
das macht sie in mexiko zu wohlhabenden
leuten und verschafft ihnen einen großen
spielraum die einzige region auf der
welt wo es wichtig ist dass mein größter
respekt durch das was mir mit diesem
kapital natürlich von mexikanischen
verhalten ist überdurchschnittlich aber
vor dass man gierig wird und die nicht
vor dafür vergesse und schnitzen und das
darf mir passieren weil wenn das
passiert dann kommt man schnell in
problemen und ausschneiden betrachters
ein falscher holz ihnen wird das ist
wahr
[Musik]
und ein hdmi kabel box die parkpflege
ist ein festes ritual für stefano wie
schon in der schweiz immer freitags bei
papier ali in liestal
natürlich und da muss jetzt hat der
planer nur warum machen
seit ihrer ankunft sind die beiden zum
ersten mal allein unterwegs ohne onkel
fernando und seinem clan hinein in ein
mexiko voller widersprüche und extreme
ich habe gestern eine zieht der
hersteller sieht das sind einfach zu
viele gäste 240 exekutionen in 15
starter von mexiko und noch eine sport
auch schon andere freilich als für uns
uns speziell mit der eigenen webseite
vorhaben ist eigentlich okay jetzt für
einen moment wo wir sind ja noch keine
grosse fisch von duncan ad astra bissig
weil ich das nochmal und mexikaner
extrem wenig beachtung
[Musik]
steinforth ein kleiner touristenort und
vorübergehende zuhause für talkies sie
planen hier zwei monate zu bleiben
die auswanderer haben die unterkunft in
letzter minute klar machen können häuser
zur miete sind in der region kaum zu
finden
doris hat ihre kinder schon von der
schweiz aus in der schule angemeldet
die ferien sind nun vorbei in zwei tagen
geht es los
1500 franken pro monat bezahlen sie für
die villa mit pool viel geld in
südafrika
[Musik]
die kriminalität am kap ist hoch die
alarmanlage ist nur eine von mehreren
sicherheitsvorkehrungen
selbst die fenster müssen toka ist jedes
mal abschließen wenn sie das haus
verlassen so sicher ihr haus so unsicher
ihre zukunft nächste woche in südafrika
haben mika und anime ihren ersten
schultag
das schrieb verschwinden
[Musik]
silvia macht sich immer auf die suche
nach einer hebamme ihr ehemann markus
beginnt alleine mit dem umbau der junge
chef stefano navarrete erobert mexiko
für sich brauchen und die phänologie
muss zurück in die schweiz
mozilla
wie will das 9
[Musik]
auf und davon mit der mobiliar
versicherungen und vorsorge